I have a message for you to send to your
Trumpets friends the stock market was
better under President Barack Obama now
I want to be careful the stock market is
not the be-all end-all indicator of how
the economy is doing for the average
person in fact it's it's often the
opposite when stocks soar and wages stay
flat that's how inequality worsens and
further concentrates at the top and we
need to look at a whole bunch of
different indicators to really figure
out how the economy is or is not working
for the average person but trumpets and
Trump himself have hung their hats on
the stock market is how we prove that
Trump is winning and that we're doing
super well so let's do it by their
standard now there's no doubt the stock
market has performed well under Donald
Trump but so far we're about three years
into Donald Trump's first term almost to
the day it's not performing as well as
it did during Barack Obama's first three
years and the great thing about this
topic is that it's very cut and dry we
have the numbers at this point in time
during the first 36 months of each of
their presidencies the S&P 500 index
this is the broadest stock market index
of the big three down as dak and S&P 500
the S&P 500 was a 59% under Barack Obama
and 46% under Donald Trump this means
that during their first three respective
years stocks returned about 28% more
twenty eight percent not twenty eight
percentage points please don't email me
with math misunderstandings the stock
market returns twenty eight percent more
during Obama's first three years than
Trump's first three years during the
same time period just as a reference
stocks lost 17 percent under george w
bush so what is important here what's
important is that by the metric Trump
chooses Barack Obama did better is this
the best measure no is this the most
reflective measure of the economy at
large
no the stock market performance tell us
how the middle class is doing no no no
it's no the answer's no to all of these
questions but it is Trump's metric and
Trump is promoting it and his followers
fall for it I could show you any of
dozen of more tweets recently about the
stock market here's one from this
weekend where Donald Trump tweeted if
you listened to the flawed advice of
Paul Krugman at the New York Times a
newspaper that was going broke until I
came along you would have entirely
missed the record-breaking stock market
and other numbers produced since
Election Day 2016 sorry those are the
facts unfortunately no there is no
record the stock market performed better
under Obama stock market growth has
slowed down under Donald Trump now let's
do the more important analysis the more
important analysis is Trump continues to
Gaslight his followers
neither the stock market growth under
Obama nor Trump has been that notable
for the tens of millions of Donald
Trump's followers who don't own any or
barely any shares of stock anyway and
are very much like the 2010 Tea Party
movement they are cheerleading policies
and ideas and a record that is
beneficial to other people but not to
them this is not anything new in
politics particularly American
right-wing politics but let's be
thorough
trumpets once presented with these
numbers are going to trot out some
pretty predictable talking points for
example they will say when you show them
these numbers well Obama had bigger
growth because he presided over the
recovery from a recession so it's
logical that there's gonna be rebound
growth there that will be faster it's
tougher to do what Trump has done which
is to keep the growth going that's a
post facto analysis done once they are
called out for lying about Trump has
record stock market growth but for every
single one of those talking points you
can find a counterpoint the reality is
that as I've said under Democratic
presidents and I say under Republican
presidents cause and effect with gas
prices cause and effect with the stock
market and presidential policy is
difficult to pin down I don't even want
to play the game other than to remind
you when you're Trump is say the stock
market has grown more than under any
other president under Donald Trump
remind them stocks rose more during
Barack Obama's first three
then during Donald Trump's first three
years and if indeed we are heading
towards a recession at some point in the
next one to three years if there is
indeed a Trump reelection that may
result in Donald Trump presiding over
far worse numbers than Barack Obama I
don't hope that's the case I'm not
predicting it any more than just
everyday we are closer to the next
downturn that's the way our system of
booms and busts works but that indeed
may happen and then this won't even be
anything that they're talking about you
will hear nothing else about the stock
market if and when that crash takes
place in the interim numbers were better
under Barack Obama than under Donald
Trump so you're someone who enjoys
thinking about politics you love
learning about countless other topics
but you just don't have enough time in
your week to read or listen to all the
books you've been meaning to get to
blink Asst is an app that will
completely transform the way that you
absorb information and ideas because
what they do is take thousands of
non-fiction books extract the most
important insights and information and
then present each book to you as text or
audio which you can consume in just 15
minutes
imagine how well-rounded you will become
once you have the ability to read five
books in one sitting or listen to a new
book on your commute every day obviously
we should read the full versions of
books whenever we can it's what I try to
do but it is a reality that there's a
whole world of books out there that you
will never get to but blinka swill help
you get to more I just finished
listening to the way we eat now by bee
Wilson whose work I've recommended to
you before super interesting look at how
the global food system works and impacts
the way that we live you'll be able to
have conversations with people about
totally new topics you can feed your
curiosity in ways that you've never been
able to before and the best part is it's
only about eight bucks a month which
gives you unlimited access to every
single book in their catalog they have
books on politics economics philosophy
science you name it you can try it out
yourself totally free for a week and get
25% off if you decide to subscribe just
by going to blink as comm slash Pakman
I've put the link right underneath this
like the rest of us I bet you're going
into 2020 thinking about what you didn't
get around to in 2019 and your goals for
the new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you